and then
introduce you
all right
um welcome everyone to the ddps seminar
uh before we introduce our invited
speaker let's go over some rules and
Logistics first of all please mute
yourself during the talk unless you have
questions if you have questions you're
welcome to unmute and ask ask otherwise
uh please use chat room to post your
questions so that we can address them in
Q a session at the end
second today's gdps seminar is open to
external audiences so no classify this
question and finally The Talk today will
be recorded and uploaded in our YouTube
channel about it now let me introduce
our speaker today it is an honor to host
in Liang who is a goal of visiting
assistant professor of mathematics at
the Department of Mathematics of Purdue
University she earned her PhD degree in
mathematics from the Chinese University
of Hong Kong in 2021
on the uh the supervision of Professor
Jun Zhao her broad research area is in
computational and Applied Mathematics
her current research interests include
ill pose inverse problems machine
learning numerical methods for partial
differential equations and scattering
Theory today in will talk about data
assisted algorithms for inverse random
Source scattering problems please enjoy
and accept a wonderful talk and now
without further Ado let me pass the
button to in by asking one random
question as usual today's random
question is where is your favorite place
in the world
feel worthless
um
if you don't specify the location first
place of course will be home with my
loved ones the science of my loved ones
it's a home that no matter where it is
um well if you're mentioning your
location the city is Hong Kong at this
moment okay it's a nice city I've been
there once all right stage is yours
see and if your screen
okay
first of all thanks thanks to you soon
for your current invitation and
introduction so uh actually as I just
mentioned I'm a second year postdoc at
Purdue University right now and this I'm
very glad to be able to share with you
our latest work on data assisted
algorithms for inverse random Source
problems this is the joint work with
Professor Elon Wong and patiently with
who I'm currently working with at Purdue
now I will start with a brief overview
of what I will be talking about in the
next 45 minutes
we are
interested in the inverse random Source
problems so generally speaking is a
inverse problem and for inverse problems
mathematically speaking we try to
determine the unknown coefficients in
the partial differential equation
whereas the exterior measurement
this could be explained with this
diagram here now if you are interested
in a certain physicals in Long Island
and it could be modeled by a partial
differential equation then the third
physical properties of that media will
go into the special differential
equation as some coefficients in that
equation now if you have the equation
have the coefficients that you need you
can numerically solve it with standard
elements final volume fat difference and
after storing it you have the numerical
solution to that equation now the thing
I just described is what we call Direct
problem we simulate something solve for
solution
the corresponding inverse problem will
be you don't know about the physical
properties you don't know the
information about the medium and but you
have the exterior measurement of
the quantity which is the solution of
the direct problem and with this
exterior measurement and our
understanding of that partial
differential coercion we're trying to
reconstruct that physical property of
our interest
now this figure on the right hand side
is one device for solving the inverse
problems that's the electrical impedance
thermographic is a medical imaging type
of problem we attached current around
the human body we inject currents we
attach this electrodes inject currents
from these electrons and then we will
measure the voltage induced by the
current and uh of course this would be
we don't want to intrusive measurement
in this case right so with the boundary
measurement we will be able to
reconstruct the medium coefficient in
Silicon and body this is governed by
some elliptic equation
that's one concrete example of inverse
problem
now the difficulty of solving inverse
problems are
there are several typical difficulties
the first one will be it's possible that
given the measurements of the solution
that we collect you cannot unique
determine the physical property and
another thing is that it's possible that
this inversion this reconstruction is
very unstable if you have little noise
little perturbation on the measurement
measurement you collect you will get
very different reconstructed
coefficients that's not something we
want because the noise in measurements
are not avoidable
and also it may requires large-scale
computation as you might need to compute
some large-scale problems or you need to
repeatedly solving the direct problem to
get a good reconstruction and also of
course Excellence like you cannot say
for sure that you have a
accurate model and you cannot make sure
that you don't have uncertainty from the
environment these are the possible
difficulties when solving an inverse
problem
now when it comes to our problems the
inverse Source problem uh there exists
some traditional methods to solve it
that is purely based on the physical
part the understanding of the
differential coalitions if we want to
reconstruct this target Source
Distribution on the left hand side the
Reconstruction we get with the
traditional method would be like this
is actually an acceptable reconstruction
because I need to emphasize that the
measurement we have will be the uh just
the exterior maybe on the surface of a
certain domain so it's not an easy
problem and this type of reconstruction
is already possible or you can tell tell
that there are three obstacles it's just
that it's not overly accurate
also traditional methods works there are
several limitations like it only works
for certain cases and I will explain
when it works and when it won't work in
the following sections but it has
several limitations and
of course we want to have a more
accurate reconstruction that's when we
consider can we use some data assisted
approach to tackle these difficulties
and that's why we propose a two-stage
data assisted method for the first stage
we'll use some method inspired by the
traditional ones we use the physical
information to from the boundary
measurement we get some approximation of
the coefficients and in the second stage
now from the approximation to the exact
coefficient it becomes an image to image
types problem now this is all widely
started Topic in computer vision and
that gives us the uh that means we have
different algorithms that we can try if
that will improve the approximation and
we compare the performance of principal
component analysis based regression
algorithm in that space regression pics
to picks and the different type of
neural networks I will further explain
these figures in the numerical
experiments part but is this just a
comparison of the Reconstruction using
different types of data assisted
algorithms as the second stage
the physical based numerical model is
accurate and Justified because we know
that model but they may not be available
as I have to have some constraints that
whether you can use the traditional
method or not
and data can be appropriately
Incorporated to address these
difficulties
and how to combine traditional methods
and the data-driven method is an
important research question and machine
learning techniques in computer vision
are useful for Imaging problems
especially for the image to image tasks
with this observations will propose our
methods which successfully combine the
physical information and the data we
have
so now let's get started going to
details about this uh the board that
I've mentioned
now the first question what are the
scattering problems
the inverse random Source problem in the
title is one of inverse scattering
problem
scattering problem concerns the
interaction between widths and medium
with propagation happens everywhere we
could be talking about acoustic waves
electromagnetic waves elastic waves Etc
I'm talking now that I'm a source of
some acoustic width and use the light
everywhere light is electromagnetic
width and the settings may like this you
have a point source access here it will
induce some electrical electric field
with noted by ee when that electric
curve filled propagate it could interact
with something like this that would be
obstacle it may not penetrate this
obstacle so we need to add some boundary
condition around it and the wave will
propagate and it will cross this
interface as and it might have different
medium coefficients above s and Below s
so the real field will of course becomes
different and this process like oh if we
know about where it's a source not the
obstacle now the interface then solving
for the wave field e that's the direct
problem and the corresponding inverse
problem will be maybe we don't know
where is that Source or maybe we don't
know where is that obstacle but we have
the measurement of the wind field EE
around this playing Gamma One then we'll
try to reconstruct to recover with a
source code where the obstacle or the
shift of this interface as that will be
inverse problem
now uh English Gathering problem can be
categorized in search industry types the
first class will be inverse medium
problems it's widely used for
geophysical exfoliation seismic Imaging
actual song thermography or biomedical
images if we are considering this type
of applications we have arrogant here
the select or point source that will be
acoustic with and we can measure from
the hydrophones here measure the wave
field then we want to also the wave
propagate along all the three layers of
mediums and we want to recover the
medium coefficients of this medium that
will tell us the properties of these
mediums
another type inverse off Circle problems
is foreign
detection non-destructive testing remote
sensing Etc this stimulus setting as the
previous one we still have a shift here
we want to we still measure the world
field above the sea and we want to
recover the shape of the sea flow that
sea flow automobile now this time we're
interested in that surface
and the last class will be inverse salt
problem that is the type of problems we
mainly focus on in this work inverse
Source problems are used for medical
imaging antenna design and synthesis
these two figures illustrate the Meg
tomography which is another type of
medical tomography
problems we have devices like this and
we will collect the electromagnetic
field around the head and with when we
recover the source that induced the
electromagnetic field that we measured
we will know the sovere the source how
that is distributed will give us give
the doctor the information to
diagonalize certain beliefs
now there are still one ingredient in
the title that I haven't mentioned
that's Randomness we need to take
Randomness into consideration in a sense
that inverse problems can involve
uncertainties due to the
unpredictability of the environment in
complex knowledge of the system random
noise of the measurements or fine scale
fluctuation in simulation
that again as I'm talking I'm the source
of acoustic word but there are also air
conditioner or refrigerator near me they
are also making some they are also sauce
and they are the noise
accompanied my uh and combinate the
source that we want to reconstruct so
the unpredictability of the environment
needs to be considered and it will go
into the differential cohesion things
will become a stochastic differential
cohesion
and here is a list of several of income
lists of researchers who are working on
the inverse problems involving
randomness
and there are increasing interest in
both theoretical and numerical studies
of the random inverse problems
now I really need to show some partial
differential equations now inverse
random Source problems under our
consideration is governed by this
stochastic and boss equation
equation comes from the wave equation is
a Time harmonic form of the width
equation and it used to model the
acoustic wave or electromagnetic waves
in certain constraints
now for this equation that U denotes the
wave field that we can measure will
field U and this capacity knows the wave
number is a constant positive number
related to the property of the wave
field this ETA
it reflects the probability of the
inhomogeneous medium it's a function
against with different value at
different location and rather than that
f is the source that induces such a
field
we need to add this one line which we
call Summer field radiation condition to
ensure that this direct problem has a
unique solution that is if we know Kappa
we know ETA will not have solving for
that oil field U is a real post problem
we need this Summerfield radiation
condition it basically tells us that
when the wheel propagates uh far far
away from the region it will decay in a
certain rate
now stochastic part comes from the
source f
the social F we model it as a random
function driven by an additive white
noise that is f is equal to
deterministic function G Plus or
determinant State function H times the
what noise
here G and H are two deterministic real
value functions and uh need to emphasize
that if the right hand side is only a
deterministic function then the problem
is well studied the direct problem is a
common one but if we add the white noise
to it the all the previous theoretical
results need to be checked again because
we don't even have a weak solution to
this equation and we only have the Melt
solution but we prove we can justify
that it has a continuous modification
the related regularity results are shown
in these two work
now corresponding inverse problem
if we have measurements of this radiated
refer to you and the boundary of the 4
with radius r as standard money with
numbers we want to recover the statistic
properties of the source that is we want
to recover the average G and the
variance H Square
now the problem
um although this is uh looks like it's a
simple equation but there are different
cases for the Reconstruction related to
this medium coefficient ETA we are not
going to reconstruct this either but it
will cause a difference when we do the
Reconstruction if this ETA equal to zero
that is homogeneous media under our
constellation it's a rather easy problem
and for the second case this ETA is not
equal to zero but we know the
distribution of ETA then this is a
slight this is a more difficult question
to answer can we recover F and for the
third case we know that ETA is not equal
to zero but we don't know the
distribution of ETA that is we have
unknown in continuous media can we
recover f
for these three cases there there exists
previous methods or for some of them for
case one we have homogeneous made up the
way to tackle it is to formulate it as
an integral equation and then use Cosmos
methods to to reconstruct the source for
the second case it is not equal to zero
but we know the distribution we can
solve an eigenvalue problem and then use
Cosmos method to reconstruct it for
circuits that's an open problem like we
have ether we don't we don't know ETA we
don't know source and we don't know
Source it's hard to recover that Source
F without the information of the media
and that's where our methods would work
now because as I mentioned the
traditional method for the case one will
become the first stage of our the method
we proposed so we I will for the next
section I will give you detailed
explanation about how the uh first how
the traditional method works for the
first case
no
solution to that ham host equation with
the homogeneous media
have this type of solution formula
that's ux could solution could be
represented with this integral of small
G and capital G and is involved between
the bad noise and the fundamental
solution G is a fundamental solution in
two-dimensional case it will be a
hangover function
next we can take expectation and
variance on both sides of this solution
formula and take the real part we get
the first line take the imaginary part
of the gets the second line take
variance from both sides and deducts the
imaginary part from the real part we get
the third line
now
for this three equations
the same I colored as blue will be the
map where we can take measurements
throughout this wave field and the same
are colored red the other things we want
to reconstruct so all three equations
can be represented as an operator
equation that AJ represented rather than
this integral operators we have hollow
information about the current of them
the reason why I need to do this
deduction this combination of the raw
part and the imaginary part of the
variance is that this one has a this
this actually discretized this part we
get a better post agent it has singular
value decays uh more slowly than with a
single imaginary or single real part
now not forget about the pde now we'll
just recovering this unknown G or H
which is a q here from the measurement
of the boundary data with finite many of
different wave numbers teaching recover
queue from P that's all some linearity
problem right
now we're gonna use the regularized
block Cosmos method to solve it
and for the inner iteration we do this
type of
updates and this could be Illustrated
with this diagram here with initial gas
Cube zero we project it onto the
solution plane corresponding to the
first operatory coercion integral
operator position and then we project it
to the second solution hyperplane and to
the third do this iteratively initially
eventually it will converge to the
solution we want that's the regularized
cosmos method here we add this gamma as
a regularization parameter because this
AJ starts to open your post your
conditioned Matrix
now I've been talking about this
traditional method there are limitations
to it as I mentioned
um
recall recall that
this feature what we call the
measurement comes from the left hand
side of these equations we need to take
expectation and balance of the
measurements we collected
and this could be achieved by taking a
lot of realizations and use the sample
mean right
that means there's no way that you can
get a great approximation with
um
without a large number of localizations
actually more than one thousand
realizations are needed to reconstruct
the average and even more to achieve
satisfying reconstruction of the
variance
and here is some figures to illustrate
this facts this is the target we want to
reconstruct the source we want and this
is the reconstruction with penualization
this is with 100 this one with one solid
validation
and you can see that we have to use
enough realization together satisfactory
reconstruction and secondly the sequence
qk we get from Cosmos method it will
converge to a minimum known solution
which is quite blurry and so one here
it's quite blurry and moreover for case
three when you don't know the
distribution of the medium then you
can't derive the integral equation at
all here this AJ comes from this right
hand side this comes from the
fundamental solution we have to have
information of the partial differential
operation to write a
fundamental solution and when we have no
information about the medium this can't
be derived
and we have some more theoretical
results related to this limitations if
we use Cosmos methods to find the limit
of that q qk and
the arrow for each iteration
between the iteration and the minimum
Norm solution we want can be decomposed
into the noise error and iteration Arrow
the iteration Arrow will Decay when you
have more more iterations but the noise
Arrow according to our analysis here it
will have an upper bound and this upper
bound is proportional to K which means
if you have noise in your measurements
this PJ it will actually increasing when
you do more and more iterations and this
coin starts with our numerical results
like if you use Cosmos when you do more
motivation the measurement will the
noise in the measurement will
deteriorate your reconstruction
so that's why I can't do a lot of
iterations
so our observation will be like this
this thing I just mentioned those
physical based numerical model is indeed
accurate and Justified but they may not
be available for certain cases like if
you don't have information about the
medium and also the data can be um but
we know that data can be appropriately
Incorporated to address this
difficultness so now let's consider if
machine learning techniques could help
with this reconstruction and the
physical informations that we have could
help us give us a prayer or distribution
of the
um data were used for the training in
the second stage
now I only talk about using your network
techniques for direct and inverse
problems a simple approach a direct
approach would be taking the measurement
as input takes the unknown parameter as
output change the neural network in the
regression
Manner and we know that this is not
going to work very well but as I
mentioned the measurement we collect are
on the boundary of the survey of the of
the domain and the unknown distribution
the non-parameter Y is in the whole
domain it's like you're using the
one-dimensional data to reconstruct a
two-dimensional reconstruction if you
choose it as a black box there's not
likely it's not likely that you can
success in the recovery
in the Reconstruction process
so uh there have been other attempts for
the inverse scheduling problems here we
just list four this is just an
incomplete list people try to combine
the physical information and data in
different ways and I also need to
mention that there are a number of
methods to use the neural network to
solve the forward problem to solve the
pde they are also useful tools for
inverse problem because traditional way
to solve inverse problems will be casted
into a minimization problems and to
solve the minimization problem you need
to repeatedly solve the direct problem
and this neural network related
algorithm will accelerate this process
and also to learn that mapping is also
kind of one one one one of the operator
learning process software neural
operator and some other algorithm also
works pretty good for this type of
problems and our methods is different
from the previous mentioned ones in a
sense that we use the physical
information in the first stage and to
and use the neural network the image to
image type of algorithm for the second
stage
now in the first stage we will use the
thing we just mentioned
the cosmos algorithm for the integral
equation giving that TJ the measurements
we don't do a lot of iterations okay
because the monitorization you do the uh
the larger the noise level the noise
Arrow will become so just do several
iterations to get an approximation g0 h0
now we get the image
so for the second stage we learned the
mapping between the approximation image
t0 to the exact G approximated h0 to the
exact edge with them different Mass
algorithms for the image to image type
of problems
and we'll test this four different types
of algorithms for the second stage the
first one will be the Principal
component analysis based regression
algorithm second one is a compositional
equipment operator tab third one be the
unit based regression gruesome and the
fourth one will be fixed to fix your
network
for the first two of them we basically
just First Carry Out the dimension
reduction and then we of the input and
output space and then apply linear
regression the difference in the in a
sense that we use different way to do
the dimension reduction
and you can imagine that third and the
fourth one related to neural network
works much better than the previous two
linear regression type so I will mainly
focus on the third and the fourth one
explain a little bit about how they
actually works
now in that best regression should be
explained with this diagram
unit based neural network will be uh
encoder decoder architecture like this
now from here to here from the
measurement to the input image that's
where we use the cosmos method for the
integral equation once you get after
several iterations you get a
approximation image here from this image
to this image there will be a
Contracting path
and a expansion expensive paths
and uh for each block we have this
convolution plus convolution layer batch
normalization and renew layer the
difference between this unit and the
traditional
um
convolution on your network will be we
have this steep connection here
therefore we can preserve the features
of the input image with this skip
connections the feature maps are passed
to the corresponding layer in the
expensive test We Are The Escape
connections and this is widely used
metal for the medical imaging to do the
segmentation
for the training process we will
minimize this L1 Arrow as a loss
function
now the fourth algorithm will be the
fixed fixed algorithm is a conditional
generative adversal neural network could
be Illustrated with this diagram for the
organ type of neural network we need to
train the generator and the
discriminator which are two neural
networks jointly the input of the
generator will be the image and output
of the generator will be also image
input of the discriminator will be a
pair of image and output output will be
a scalar between 0 and 1.
and that jointly trained in the
competitive manner as the generator
wants to generate the image resemble the
target coefficient and the discriminator
will attempt to differentiate between
the real Pairs and the generated Health
but real paths will mean the paths
coming from the training data and
generated paths means that this x and
the output of the generator this test
would be what we call thick hairs
this objective can be achieved by
dealing with this loss function the this
is a banner request entropy type the
generator will check will be trained to
minimize this one and the discriminator
trains to maximum this one it's a
conditional gain we need to add another
term this term is about the is the Lost
terms for the generator because we want
the generator to
assemble the
um to mimic the exact coefficient
now in the picks to fix algorithms the
generator's architecture will be again
the unit and the patch game will be used
as the discriminator
now finally that's present some
numerical experiments for the training
set we have 2000 samples each with three
cylinder inclusions which are randomly
samples the position reduce and
magnitude that randomly sampled the
measurements we have will be the
synthetic data of 100 realizations of
average reconstruction and we need 1000
realizations for variance reconstruction
this is this is already one tenth of the
relation realization needed for a
satisfactory reconstruction for
traditional method
and the measurement will be measured as
Route 32 uniform distributed points on
the on the circle now the source will be
this world of thoughts will be within
this SQL and we have measurements along
this circle at 32 point
and we have five wave numbers
now some numerical results this is the
average reconstruction in the
homogeneous medium from left to right we
have that's the exact source that we
want to reconstruct the average of the
source second column is the cosmos
reconstruction the thing we get from the
first stage
third column will be the PCA based
regression result
both column will be the complement.bmd
type reconstruction and this one from
unit this column from the pics to picks
algorithm
we can observe that from here from the
left to right we get a more and more
complicated uh model but we get better
and better reconstruction we have a
table here like for the training time
PCA and cockman we use we need last time
and for unit and picks to picks when you
choose one is 75 minutes of 75 seconds
and more than 10 minutes for these
topics but the relative error of the
case
in this manner but we will say that
pixel picks actually have a slightly
larger relative Arrow compared with
units but if you tell from the image
you'll see that it actually give us a
better give us a Sharper Edge
now this is a variance reconstruction
the Reconstruction of H Square
um it's this this is a lot of powder
problem and we have to find the same
observation from the left but uh get
better and better construction and same
observation here from the relative L1
Arrow
now these are experiments for case three
recall that case three is when you don't
know about the media how to do the
Reconstruction of the source
and those are not existing traditional
method for it but this is our
reconstruction the first two rules are
about average construction and these two
rules above the various circumstances
average this for variance from the left
to right we still get better and better
reconstruction if you compare this
figure with the previous figure we will
see that's the cosmos reconstruction the
same we get from the first stage
these are much worse than the previous
ones because we don't actually know the
exact model because we don't know the
median but the first stage is based on
the fundamental solution of the
homogeneous meta so there's
but still even with a much worse initial
condition the with the help of this data
assist algorithm will get pretty good
reconstructions
now this is a generalization test recall
that for the training data set we use
the three inclusions type the cylinder
inclusions and if we test our result for
the like here we have five cylindering
Solutions and from the this row we have
the simplified Phantom tab we have
ellipse inside a little ellipse shaped
inclusions since we still get pretty
good reconstructions
okay and here I complete with some
ongoing and future work as I mentioned
there are all different type of
scattering problems and the inverse
Source problem we just mentioned is
actually a linear Tab and here we
consider the inverse obstacle problems
that is uh this is a differential
equation under consideration we want to
recover this shape of the speed
and this is a clearly non-linear problem
and this is the Reconstruction we have
we also use some some traditional
methods not integration but some direct
probing tab with uh with the
measurements we collect we could get
this type of
Reconstruction from the traditional
method then we'll learn the mapping from
this one to the exact coefficient and
this is a reconstruction we can get with
um with the same amount of training data
and you can see that there are fairly
difference between the exact obstacle
distribution and reconstruction we get
and some other ongoing work will be the
theoretical analysis for the stability
estimate for this type of inverse random
Source problems which are also off-grid
theoretical interest
and here are some references for the um
works that I have just mentioned
okay then that's all I need to talk
about thanks for being here
okay thank you so much for the wonderful
talking
um very nice result
um very impressive results
all right so let's have a q a sessions
um
anyone who has a questions you can
unmute yourself and then ask questions
um I guess while you're preparing your
questions I can ask question here
um so if you
go back to slide 28 I believe
so there's a
the comparison of the results
you know among four different
the
the data driven approach data assisted
approach
here you set the time of the unit is 74
and the chicks to pix is 7 200 729
that's the training time yeah that's for
training
uh and when you do the training I assume
you use a lot of you know data yes in
supervised manner
yeah
and once you're done with the training
you know actual
this predictions or evaluation of that
the source
locations where the source comes
it's a it's very fast right yeah testing
takes no time like
um for the first stage yes you still
need to do the cosmos but it takes uh
not comparable to the training time and
for the second stage you already get the
trained neural networks so takes no time
yeah so I mean
it looks like there's a offline and
online yeah
yeah
where you can collect the data from that
physics-based inverse problem yeah and
you match those with a known the source
arms
and
that you train the unit and picks to
picks and once that is done
you know you can try that on to new
Source terms but
because there is a two stages the first
stage you still have to solve inverse
problems you know in traditional way
right yeah so that takes time yeah that
that's
a
solving uh
so basically we just stop this equation
right and we solve it with uh Cosmos if
we only do several iterations then this
thing takes takes no time because this
is not really that large
a is not that large
how does the size of the a determines
now
um
so for example here we have in our here
we got some 64 times 64 pixels so the
inputs of this this Matrix a it will be
this Q that's from the unknown G or H so
it will have six to four times 64 as the
uh I see the the one side of the Matrix
and for another part that will be PJ
that's the boundary measurement so that
would be 64 times 4. one and actually
that's from the boundary measurement we
use a 32 measured points so that's
actually just sort of 32 okay
and the a matrix here is dance Matrix
it will be with these types of pronouns
so
yes it's a dance Matrix
yeah
so the if the pixel size is bigger that
dense Matrix becomes bigger
um yeah I guess
as long as we deal with the
two-dimensional image
I guess it we can handle that yeah so
another difficulty also lies in the
preparing for the data like for each
sample will need 100 or once on
realizations for each realization you
need to solve the forward problem once
so for each sample you need to solve it
1000 times yeah yeah
because that's a problem yeah
yeah
well that's the problem of any data
driven approach generating data is not a
easy task all right sounds good is there
any questions from audiences audience
well if not I have one more question so
if you can clarify you know
how you apply the command
I'm human type
data assisted methods so PCA it's clear
to me you you do some sort of SPD
yeah yeah so for PCA yeah we listed with
just got them as the doctors and
concatenate the two records yeah for
pizza you can just do it separately we
do the aspected conversation for the
input image listed once and they said
that's all for Matrix and we separately
do Associated for the output image ones
and we need you start use Sigma weight
conversation with
um the new
um the redacted Dimension reducted new
A8 will be
um you transpose uh the data and B and
the sigma inverse from so yeah they're
from the difference
you come up with some linear operator
right yeah yeah that's one thing that's
why I have a little bit doubt about how
to
um say it and name of this algorithm we
do so we don't actually have the dynamic
system yeah but we'll just let's just do
one step dynamic system from from from
like here to here so we just see it as a
one step dynamic system
okay and and then you have a bunch of
different
um the previous step and then you know
next step and you just pair them
yeah come up with the approximate linear
operator
um
that's that's what you do for the
command operator okay
got it
okay
have you have you tried you know
completely getting rid of the the
physics the first stage
yeah that that will be that would be
very hard that'll be very hard to train
like to start with if you don't use the
first stage what you have is the just a
I I don't have the figure showing the
solution but if you have this type of
source the solution will be the
oscillating the wave distribution and
what you have is only the so there will
be a circle we measured around the
circle it will be just a curve even if
you have five curves because we will
have five real numbers it's hard to get
from the curve to the whole interior
distribution it's the dimension does not
match
I see
all right
okay
um we have a question from
petrol uh do you want to unmute and ask
Yes actually um the first stage when you
do it three iterative solution how do
you select stop in criteria how do you
decide when to stop iterations
yeah that's that's a great question is
how to decide because we have some
theoretical results here that exactly
because the noise comes from the the
measurement noise and also the arrow of
the t comes from the mean by mean sample
meanings so it's unavoidable so it will
increase the noise will increase
so it's how to do that so eventually we
decided just to do fabrication for five
iterations and stop
and that's why you you don't have a very
good reconstruction here
but it's not guaranteed that you do more
iteration you will get a better one it
might get even worse the construction
should we just decide to do only several
steps once you get a reasonable initial
approximation we stop
show that slide with liama
can you say that again could you please
show the slide when you
which about your error construct no no
no no previous previous videos Subway at
the beginning
okay
at the beginning yeah
you should just uh
recently when I asked you about
um
[Music]
uh
um as the iteration goes up the error is
increasing yeah that's in that here yeah
yeah
so
tell me to understand you who have to to
seek my gamma here which is which
yeah uh this Sigma gamma is related is
the smallest now there are singular
value of this operator comes from the um
so it's all these metrics are related to
um
something about the kernel here and
here that's Turtle gamma this one is
proportional to the auto arrow so this
one is fixed we know that it exists
now let me distant uh system system of
equations so uh P J is your data right
PJs comes from our measurement data yeah
yeah so PPG is just one data point it's
a scholar right
future
um
here is a vector after this grid has a
sub Vector black 32 by 1 vector
okay so okay so it's it's Vector at one
position okay and Q is your image right
you is oh yeah use our uh so Q is our
image that we want so so basically a AJ
is your
operator like uh uh three dimensional
operator which Maps two-dimensional
image to one dimensional Vector right
yeah correct correct okay thank you
thank you very much very interesting
thank you
I agree it's a very interesting work
um any other question
well if not let's thank our speaker Ian
for the wonderful talk
um yeah thank you so much Ian thank you
um and after this talk hopefully you
know you know fruitful collaborations
will set up
um and yeah let's hope for that okay
thank you
and thank you everyone